throughout every culture or branch of
mythology there is always at least one
iconic hero and in fact most of the time
there are many more today we travel to
island to discuss : an Irish hero who
has been likened to the Greek hero
Achilles in terms of his reckless
courage the ability to inspire fear in
his enemies and he's part mortal pot
immortal persona : has gone by several
names over the years including kou :
kou : and of course most commonly among
Irish people as kou :
his name itself meant cool UNS hound the
name of a blacksmith that he would
eventually serve as we've already
mentioned he was an Irish hero but he
was also the central figure of the
Ulster cycle a series of Legends and
sagas that took place in medieval Island
many believed that he was in fact the
incarnation of his father Lou the
warrior and Savior of the toward a
Danone his mother on the other hand was
a mortal making him what many would
consider to be a demigod his appearance
is commonly described as a small young
man with no beard and thick black hair
and then you have some truly peculiar
nod descriptions of him my favorite of
these being that his hair was brown at
the base blood-red in the middle with a
crown of yellow surrounding it he had
four dimples in each cheek yellow-green
crimson and blue seven bright pupils in
each eye each foot had seven toes in
each hand had seven fingers his nails
resembled a Hawks claw or a Griffin's
clinch now as you can see these
depictions do vary quite dramatically
and it might have been a case of his
image changing over time to appear more
terrifying : is a figure that we can
almost equate to an old Irish Incredible
Hulk as he would enter trances of
superhuman rage and once the need for
violence and anger to come to an end he
will return to a much more gentle and
sensitive being these transformations
became visible even from a very young
age when he first became part of a group
of boys being trained at the fortress
Amane maka he ran onto the playing field
without asking for any of the older boys
permission or protection unaware of this
custom the other boy saw this as a
challenge of their abilities and they
began to attack a young hero in sere
that coup : habit was known as arias
threat this process is often described
as a wharf spasm
truly disturbing transformation his
muscles would rapidly expand
he's electra-twist themselves backwards
one eye would be sucked inside of his
head and the other one would fall
outward hanging from his face his cheek
spilled themselves away from his mouth
revealing his jaw and his internal
organs were now visible he said would
stand up in the shape of a spike so
strong that he could secure an apple and
from his forehead would spurt streams of
blood unto his enemies in short his body
would turn itself inside out when driven
into one of these fits of rage and on
this particular occasion he proceeded to
beat every single boy who attacked him
with only one hand it didn't take long
before the boys would ask to be placed
under Colin's protection a rather
Setanta as he was known at that time
Coulomb was not the name that he was
born with it was a name that he was
later given the name his mother gave him
was the tantor when the king of austell
was invited to a banquet at the house of
cullen the blacksmith he asked his
nephew setenta to accompany him when
they arrived setenta joined in on a
hurling game of some of the other boys
the king was so impressed by his nephew
that he invited him to join in on the
feast so tantor accepted his uncle's
request but only once the game had
finished and unfortunately the King
forgot to tell Colin of his nephews
invitation when he saw a stranger
approaching he unleashed his ferocious
hound this stranger was of course
setenta and offs had been attacked by
the Hound he had no choice but to defend
himself eventually killing the dog the
way setenta defeated the hound like many
things in Irish mythology was quite
graphic still holding the whole import
from earlier the boy flung the ball into
the hounds throat and then proceeded to
smash the hounds head against the stone
courtyard when Curran sought had
happened to his hound he was devastated
sat on tuition to atone for his actions
then promised to rear the Smith a new
hound but until it came of age he
himself would protect Colin's house the
druid Kath bet and then announced that
the boy's name from this day would be
called Hollen
meaning Cullen's hound when training a
team a mecca the Jewish cath bed was
asked a very particular question as to
what the significance of the current day
was to which she replied that any
warrior that took arms on this day would
have ever lost in fame and glory
naturally : over here Ernest went
straight to his uncle and asked to take
up arms despite only being seven years
old
when that you had saw the boy take arms
he began to immediately grieve as the
prophecy he had heard was not finished
any worry that took up arms on this day
would be extremely famous but in
exchange his life would also be
extremely short column was given the
Kings chariot and he traveled to the
sons of nekton who had boasted of
killing more Osterman than there were
Osterman alive when he even should
return to the fortress all of the men
were terrified that his battle rage
would kill them all the King's wife
devised the plan to distract him by
leading the women of the E Main outside
bare-breasted
and for the most part this distraction
worked as the Osterman were able to
wrestle him to the ground fur in barrels
of water on him until he called down and
returned to his normal state despite how
unpleasant Conan looked during his walk
spasms when he was a normal young man he
was described as possess an untold
beauty so much so that the other men of
Ulster were worried that without his own
wife he would attempt to take theirs so
they began to search all of the lands
for a suitable wife the only woman that
they found that coholan showed any
interest in was Emma the youngest
daughter of foggle monarch now as you
can expect forego hearing of Colin's
unpredictable nature was against the
idea and suggested that before he
married his daughter he traveled to
Scotland in the land of Alba and terrain
of the renowned female warriors Katoch
in hopes of the young warrior would be
killed
: not being one to back away from a
challenge accepted and traveled to dun
scathe otherwise known as a fortress of
shadows to begin his training for war in
the meantime plan to offer his daughter
to loo Gaede one of the kings of monster
but when the King had heard that Emma
was in love with Colin he refused to
take her hand in marriage meanwhile back
in the fortress of Shadows kohonen began
to learn all of the arts of war and it
wasn't too long before his mentor came
up against her fiercest rival and battle
Aoife Skotak fearing that the young boy
was not ready for a better of this
magnitude gave him a sleeping potion to
keep him away but because of his immense
strength this only worked for an hour or
so and he would eventually join the
battle anyway the two are very closely
matched in battle belief who became
distracted when her horse fell off a
cliff with he sought to her throat Colin
chose not to kill her on one condition
that she bore him a son
so Carolyn returning from Scotland with
a child runaway was expecting to marry
Emma
but for boy was still refusing to bless
their union so naturally : does what
every rage induced hero would do and
storms for twas fortress cannon 24 of
his men abduct a NEMA and stealin all of
four will straighter along the way it
wasn't in - around 8 years later at
conlou the son of Kahlan and Aoife would
come to island looking for his father
when he refused to identify himself the
hero killed him who's taken him to be an
intruder the boys lost words to his
father well that they could have carried
the flag of Ulster - Roman beyond
leaving : stricken by the realization
that he had slain his own son perhaps
all of the heroes greatest achievements
were single-handedly defending Ulster
from the Army of connect at the age of
17
the Queen of Connect took the men of
Ulster by surprise when our young hero
failed to notice her army crossing the
border because he was with a woman at
the time with the use of a curse she
managed to disable the men of Ulster as
the only men unaffected coholan was the
last line of defense and he managed to
stop the army advancing any further by
invoking the right of single combat he
proceeded to defeat every single one of
the connect champions that were thrown
his way
one day after slaying one of the connect
champions a young woman appeared to him
claiming that she was a daughter of a
king and she offered him her love when
he refused she reveals herself as the
Morrigan and swears revenge upon him she
appeared in several different forms
attacking Colin unable to best him
regardless of whatever form she took
with the Morgan heavily wounded she
appeared to him one last time as an
elderly woman milking a cow she offered
him three drinks of milk and for every
one that he took she was further blessed
eventually healing her wounds entirely
journeys closest combat yet he barely
managed to emerge victorious leaving
himself extremely wounded he would visit
the great warrior Liu who healed his
wounds and also told him that he was in
fact his father when qu colon returned
he saw that his uncle's army had
attacked the army of connect and lost
this sent him into his most severe and
spectacular rheostat of all time he
charged into the opposing army killing
hundreds and building walls from their
corpses he single-handedly caused the
army to retreat with Coquelin curse to
die at a young age that death will
eventually come when three children of
the men he killed conspired
him in Ireland there were several taboos
and they was thought of someone was to
break one of these taboos they would
become extremely weak physically and
spiritually
one of the biggest taboos was eating dog
meat but refusing ones hospitality or
scene is even worse so when he was
approached by an old crone offering him
dog meat he had no choice but to break
one of these taboos and accept the food
this of course left him spiritually
weakened and there were three magical
Spears made the first would kill his
charity the second he's hoarse and the
third would mortally wound him knowing
that his fate was unavoidable he tied
himself to a stone so he could die
stand-in rather than on his knees
despite giving everything he had to
survive one of the Morgans Ravens would
eventually land on his shoulder showing
his enemies that he was finally dead
when one of them an approached attempted
to cut off his head there was a beam of
light that surrounded Cal Holland this
beam of light burned the man's hand
causing him to drop his sword and cut
off his own arm
this light continued to radiate around
Cal Hollen until he sawed almost cut
from his body the legends of Cal
holliness still told to this day the
Irish hero of immense strength and power
we essentially have this Jaclyn Hyde
figure who was feared by so many despite
being so young I've only told you a
handful of his adventures because there
were so many but I'd love to hear what
you guys think feel free to share any
thoughts and ideas with me in the
comments below and as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained